liz is with us in Illinois hi Liz
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up good good so I was
we're doing our taxes and um last year
for 2008 for 2018 we had three hundred
and sixteen thousand dollars in capital
losses we were told that we could only
deduct three thousand a year on our
taxes but I did the math and that would
take 115 years and I just I'm hoping I
don't live that long but our accountant
said that he suggested opening a
brokerage account instead of a 401k to
utilize these capital losses and I just
wanted to hear your opinion on that so
it sounds like the the type of losses
that you have is what's causing the
write-off the inability to write them up
because you don't have any income that
is of similar sources to the losses
great yeah and so he's saying open a
brokerage account because the income on
that then would be tax-free utilizing
these losses to write it off okay right
exactly
I'll bite
and I don't know would you treat a
brokerage like a 401k you just let the
money build and then ya put the money
into a mutual fund and the problem is is
that if you put it in mutual funds the a
lot of the gains may not be taxable
because the growth in value is not
taxable
until you cash it out and so you're not
getting any use of this the brokerage
account where you're buying and selling
stocks if you have a gain that's all
taxable in that year it sounds like
you've got a short you need short term
income on investments not long term
capital gains on investments to offset
this what was this from what's the loss
from from trading I'm doing trades Jesus
yeah it was bad it was a bad situation
my husband was diagnosed as being
bipolar but not until after this
happened and we just all happened within
six weeks it was just kind of a manic
thing it was you know very out of
character and very upsetting and
obviously what is your what is your
household income um for last year oh my
gosh it was only thirty eight thousand
this year it's going up my husband got a
new job
starting at fifty thousand plus you know
whatever board you have three hundred
thousand that you could lose uh we had
an inherited IRA and he was work yeah
and so he was originally I had just had
a new baby okay big profit pregnancy so
he started working from home trading
because he was doing it doing well with
it until he you know yeah up until he
wasn't and so now it's it's been crying
seventy-eight percent of day traders
lose money statistically that's called
all of them okay no don't don't even
ever say that again that he was doing
well that's like saying I'm at the
roulette table and I hit so I'm doing
well
yeah yeah okay all right let's stop for
a second um the inherited IRA was
taxable
he pulled the money out and paid taxes
on it and then lost it my said yeah yeah
cuz inherited IRA is taxable when you
pull it out yeah that was bad
okay here's the problem we're if we get
to knit C and nuanced and technical in
order to get some benefit from this
write-off but it exposes him to the very
beast that just about killed him the
first time I don't like that so your
husband being anywhere near a brokerage
account sounds like suicide to me so
that's what that is a brokerage account
a brokerage account is an account that
you have with a broker that you call the
broker and you do trades okay which is
the answer is no your husband does not
need to be anywhere near that so I don't
know in your household how you're going
to create gains on investments to offset
losses on investments to get the benefit
of this that is substantial I don't know
how to do that what I would do if I were
in your shoes before before I put your
family at further risk playing with the
same snakes that already [ __ ] you I
would just say screw it forget it it's
just gone yeah okay and but yeah but
before I completely do that I want to
ask a question if I'm you because
there's 300 grand on the table of losses
that we'd be nice to shelter income with
I want to ask a different tax advisor
than you have the same question what
other accounts qualify what other
investments qualify for this right the
returns on them qualify to offset this
loss I think though you're probably
gotten pretty decent advice in terms of
what technically applies but it was a
bad advice when you pan back and
understand the situation but
your husband doesn't need to be anywhere
near a broker manic-depressive people
should not be doing trades hello you
know nobody - nobody should but bipolar
sure as crud shouldn't so I'm so sorry
what a horrible thing y'all been
thinking well we're getting through it
there was some debt that went into it a
lot of our marriage doing i'm here's a
guy that's strong you know we go to
counseling i'm very supportive of him
she healing from the bridge where you
hit him okay oh lord I can't even
imagine I'm so sorry oh yeah let's do
this let's do this let's say out loud
let's say out loud that your accountant
may have given you good tax advice but
bad mental health advice great stay away
from a brokerage now but let's also
double check and get a second opinion
and some other possible options if there
are any that are safe and that are away
from the snakes that have bitten you
before that where you could get this
right off but before I did a brokerage
account I would just lose the money it's
just part of the sadness of this whole
situation
thanks for the call anytime any time you
try to short-circuit the process a
building wealth get bit
anytime doesn't matter if you're bipolar
doesn't matter if you're a type doesn't
matter you're Enneagram number
he who hastens to be rich will not go
unpunished I did it
her husband did it don't do it
[Music]